this is always said copyright is right
the protecting rights of ownership of
authors and their original creations I
suppose on that video we oughta add sort
of not just authors which we think I was
like ideas but say inventors they were a
group explicitly mentioned Everett and
their original creations or discoveries
I suppose that we that would include
like you know scientists and that kind
of thing thing people you know discover
and you get a Nobel Prize for that
copyright covers all of those things
okay now it says we're protecting these
people because of you know reproduction
or distribution was one that was also
mentioned in the video distribution
being able to make money off it that's
all you meant by commercial purposes and
we said there's all these reasons why
copyright law is a good idea why it's
important to protect these people not
just for their sake but for hours as
well as consumers to make sure that
money is going into the industries that
provide all things we enjoy so now
clears off what I think about the fact
that in multimedia wherever this is ipt
right multimedia and the fact that it's
all digital now huh change is copyright
law big time right because copyright
laws existed before you know multimedia
went digital but it wasn't quite the
same and it didn't have the same
limitations of requirements on it okay
for instance when you are make a copy of
safe CD CD
if you were to bird right and you have
another CD now okay which has say you
know it's an album or something like
that what's the difference between these
two cds know how would you cut it how
would you describe the difference well
you know maybe there's like yeah was
legitimately nervous think right okay so
you know your original or not original
but maybe you know the one that you
purchased that one was created by people
who had the copyright yeah okay often
same over to be back music exhale album
so it was created by the what I call
recording companies that kind of thing
right and they have the rights to do
that want to create the copy it was
created by different people and so the
rights have not been carried over but
here's the important thing ok what is
what is the actual part of this CD
that's the important part I've been
album on it and the city itself is like
sort of plastic and some metals and all
that kind of thing but the important
part of it is this is the course right
it's the data it's that literally it's
the zeros and ones that actually make up
the music that we're listening to right
and that part that part is identical
it's literally exactly the same and this
is what puts a problem by the way this
wasn't always the case before CDs how do
people buy music before CDs I know this
is before time okay so are alternatives
to this right when things like vinyl
records now that's going way way back
there was something major in between
what was it between cassette tapes right
ok now the gramophone is interesting the
gramophone vinyl records they were
subject to nearly as much your piracy
that kind of thing because vinyl records
are quite hard to produce right it's not
easy to be quite specialized machinery
but what the cassette tape was
introduced everything
changed right because what's a cassette
tape made out of what the actual with
your plastic right and like there's a
there's a magnetic fill right now the
thing about these the important our
quality about this is that they're very
cheap to produce I'm very cheap to buy
like you know just a few dollars you can
get them you can mass you know purchase
right so what happened was with the
introduction of cassette tapes improve
it sort of led to a massive brutal egg
industry they went right it's about
copying things without you know without
my permission ok because copying became
so much more easy right but can you see
how now that things are this is this is
all analog right moving over to digital
because make better step up right and I
think we would say you know CDs now
actually they're pretty CDs are pretty
old-fashioned now aren't they what have
we moved to what kind of model we've got
to we've gone to youtube and enter
iTunes right so both of these now
they've made it one step further you see
how it continues to cause problems of
copyright law and people wreck it went
from difficult to produce to easier to
produce and purchase but still when you
make the copies it wasn't identical like
it is your CD so one more step and now
here there's not even a physical thing
that you have to actually get you can
just download it right or in the case of
YouTube as you watch the video there are
tools out there to actually just remove
the audio portion out if that's what
you're after okay so how does copyright
law and you know this is unjust Vittorio
music think about software and prove all
those kinds of things right how's
copyright law and particularly copyright
act had to adjust there are two main
adjustments that had to be produced so
let me explain is to house the Copyright
Act Vita been divid now that all of this
data between those digital
okay number one you are allowed we are
allowed to make a single copy of
anything any data any program any audio
that kind of thing that you've purchased
right you're allowed to make just one
but for a specific purpose they don't
know what it is backup purposes now no
matter what it is you have that because
they know in reality your CDs get
scratched that kind of thing you're not
intending to try to do this is about the
purpose statement right um you don't
intend to make money off it you're just
trying to make sure that you'll be able
to keep on using the thing that you've
paid for right like it so you can make a
single copy that's the first way that um
valve Wars being the Act has been
amended secondly if you are self right
or transfer ownership of such data ok
suppose you're like I bought this copy
of photoshop I don't need photoshop
anymore I was doing a project and now
I'm finished ok if you sell or transfer
ownership of that what must you do with
the copies that already exists because
copying is what happens when you install
something right well if you sell a
transfer ownership sorry all copies all
the existing copies that you're in
possession off must be destroyed ok you
see how this this clause wasn't
necessary when we just had data that was
just physical right when I give you a
book it's not like I still have a copy
of a book left Omaha going to burn it ok
because now you had it right like the
video Seth right if I take it from you
you don't have it anymore but in terms
of digital data it's not the same right
all right I sell or transfer ownership
it goes to someone else's hands but I
sort of still have it so I actually
interactively do this okay all right now